welcome to this video playing proxima
centauri from Spain okay yeah okay let's
do something a bit different not the
news of all the time I really like to
play it but need some change okay I'm
playing this e3 line this was some with
a um yeah by a different move water some
were popular in the candidates
tournament played by chronic against
Iranian and also by kayaking against
ireland from a queen's gambit move order
but they basically went into this this
structure yeah white has a very fluent
development this is nice the bishop on
b2 is not doing so much but well black
is very often playing c5 in this
structure and then the bishop will get
will get alive and i also have other
ideas going yeah in the direction of
blacks king nigeria five can be can be
an idea let's see how is going to keep
the night no night d to have six
possible but then i have 95 yeah okay
not that this is like brilliant for
white but it's an idea okay so he just
intends to play f5 it seems
it I should better be ready for that
maybe I should have played Luke see one
Luke see one is also a good idea
sometimes because it prepares 95 in a
way okay
yeah that was not ideal look see one was
interesting after FR there is 95 after
those mass trade c7 is hanging so this
is mark see one was an idea ok I don't
have I don't have any big experience
with this line yeah which this move also
confirms I didn't really think of that
who shop c1 mmm Jim Jim I need to play
that it's not exactly great mmm but what
else to do against the pin at least
that's a fairly solid position I don't
really see black am doing anything to
worm to threatening night somewhere I
don't know okay let's do this first he
might play 92 Bishop t2 okay sure takes
a three but it was looking strange
anyway ok so just night back yeah try to
play but should be 295 again
mmm yeah I thought this was this is
surprising that he actually I mcclain
may be there is a tactical justification
that's of course always the possibility
but strategically speaking combining now
this rook c3 right okay stategic ly
speaking combining f5 and NC 5 here
looks a bit strange because he's very
loose on all all francium it looks
active but it said it has left black
with with many weaknesses so I'm not I'm
not totally convinced by a black sir
setup came that seem but he's a very
active so it's not like it's total am
clear
hmm ok ok let's just activate a bit more
maybe 92 too ok i don't know i'm a bit
undecided here in this position I came
it could have played a 92 actually it's
probably really risky but maybe possible
92 m / to take on f5 I'm putting some
pressure on this long diagonal and maybe
okay I go night to be three Jim this is
this is a bit tricky or just a for ya
what is so black doing after f4 or
taking on default looks looks really
horrible
ok I cannot I cannot sacrifice some well
let's um let's clarify things here I
still should have a good play along the
along the long diagonal ok yeah I
probably didn't play it the best
possible way but I still hope I have
something but to get the King out of
this so that i can at some point really
move this knight on d4 this is bishop on
d5 is black problem it's not really
doing much ok well this should this
should be quite quite a nice attack on
the dark squares or I see him is he no I
can't go via h4 I was just asking myself
is he able to exchange Queens but not
now
yeah that that's it should probably win
age seven hangs and f6 was frettin so
didn't really have a good good job
defense okay check check okay ma'am yeah
put it only five maybe okay jack it's no
it's let's no check media I look Sam
looks really shaky but I don't see a med
chem so do time for any more prep moves
mmm i would also like to win the spawn
of course but i don't see and don't see
how so what I'm like what am I going to
do I can try to get the king / / 2 12 h
form
check okay I'll get to check at this one
okay yeah yeah this is this is winning
now hmm maybe else hmm okay yeah well
it's still wins but didn't see bishop f1
at all check my team really made some
progress on the clock here check black
for Fitz on time yeah this this turned
turned out really bad for him from from
a pretty good position I don't like c5
really maybe maybe this is ok from a
from a technical point of view just like
with concrete play that you can justify
this this use position because black has
simply made so many pawn moves like all
this at it this weekend is so back rank
and instruction but black is very active
the computer likes black quite a lot
actually with Queenie seven rupee eight
yeah it's possible it's possible why
does somewhat passive with this pieces
like those roofs for example they really
don't do much in the structure some
black must be really a quick oh yeah it
Bishop deform okay yeah well okay dad at
that since that's quite good resolute
going ok I didn't calculate this this is
of course not on and you don't really
have a square so it basically wins the
exchange okay
aha here the computer gives this move as
very good for white yeah well it looks
dangerous I'm ready to believe that I
don't see her however what exactly my
thread is hmm ok I'm let me what pie
what happens on a nothing jealous this
should be five ok well maybe get the
rook rook away from ba gia to to not
allow that lets say let's say I go here
what happens then it should be five
aware wrong the app it should be five is
a very annoying move now yeah well black
can not take because it kills him on the
F file oh ok yeah it's a very dangerous
attack that that's really true yeah and
this is probably a defensible for black
it should be the end of the world but it
got problematic really quickly I think
after this this black must avoid it or
crosses capture check and now after
Queenie one widest winning average there
the computer confirms that I'm just so
much stronger with the bishop on d4
compared to d5 that black is not going
to be able to defend it no ok thanks for
watching